like that high pass show and i i talked
a bit uh a bit about it on the patreon
mind-numbingly boring
it's just dull
these kids are they're i mean
i'm sure they're nice people
but here's the thing
that the real show is fun like they're
creating this thing that isn't real we
want the behind the scenes show us the
adderall
show us the drugs
show us the fights with the parents
show us everybody's [ __ ] talking to
demilio's because they've got the real
money
show us the real [ __ ]
but they don't do that it's a very
sanitized
safe
uh brand friendly
netflix event
we want i want kids on a
on the phone their parents go you're a
[ __ ] failure
you understand that
[ __ ] you you know what's happening dad
i'm getting my [ __ ] sucked right now by
three underage [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
what happened you leave the factory
early today you [ __ ] near-dewell
piece of [ __ ]
i'll send you 10 grand don't ever
[ __ ] call me again like that's what i
want i want people just to be like show
us the monsters
like literally the whole show is just
like these kids have lamborghinis and
mansions and they're like
sometimes
i feel that i'm not as good of friends
with everyone as i used to be
who gives a [ __ ]
kill them
you're in l.a
light their house on fire
the reason you're not as good as friends
with them is because you're breaking
through
you're gonna be big
[ __ ] up
what kind of [ __ ] is this what do you
live in minnesota you're in l.a
take your bentley and drive it through
the [ __ ]
house stop this [ __ ] stop talking about
how much you love your parents what the
[ __ ]
if we want to watch a show about 17 year
old millionaires i don't want to see how
close they are with their goddamn family
you're supposed to be a [ __ ] demon
from hell
a like a tremor that crawled through the
desert with a a fang laden mouth just
trying to [ __ ] get brand deals and
bleed everybody dry
nobody cares about your [ __ ] anxiety
for christ be
cool
is it too much to ask i'm talking about
getting canceled and afraid how scared
you are about online mobs say [ __ ] it i
don't give a [ __ ] you can't cancel this
[ __ ] like dude if i was if i was
directing that shot i'd be like stand in
front of that lamborghini and say you
can't cancel this [ __ ] and then put a
put a middle finger up and say [ __ ] yeah
i got health care
but it's boring it's why because it's
not real why is hollywood failing it's
not
real we know it's not we know you're not
nice
you're 17 with a porsche
you're not nice
there's a scene where one kid goes
should we take the g-wagon order rolls
you're not nice
and if you are nice what a waste
but you're not we get it we know you're
not nice
we know you're not thinking of other
people's feelings
we know that
we know that
and none of them really have some of
them have skills right like they're alex
warren kids funny and he has some skills
but like and then one of the little
huddy the one who thinks he's a vampire
i guess he does some music you know but
he's a vampire he's like a vampire or
something he lives in this and by the
way he really noticed the real estate in
this town is disgusting these houses in
moore park and encino these just
disgusting caves where they were where
70s era sitcom stars od'd and bathtubs
it's really grotesque um
and
what is this it's their house yeah but
that's not their house hold on
is this the new house
right here
this is it yeah that's it listen
is that nice
is that nice
no i'm asking
is this nice
can you go to little huddy's house that
thing's terrifying looking it's a casita
right it's like a casita
i don't know what the hell it is
it's an applebee's i think they called
it huddy's hacienda right huddy's
hacienda show that
look at that
that's a theme restaurant at disney
world
you would put tables and chairs outside
of that and serve fat tourist churros
this state is a black hole when it comes
to culture i'm from the hamptons [ __ ]
off
i mean look at that it's you know one of
the kids in the show goes it's like
let's surfer kid with the he has like
his name's jack right he's like
terrifying so what he does is this all
day he goes
he just smiles like but he's very
uncomfortable you know what some people
smile like very uncomfortable his smile
is very uncomfortable it's like
it's very it's scary
and uh he he goes like this he goes yeah
it's kind of like cheesecake factory i
love it just get fat yeah
a lot but my problem is they're all
trying to be nice the last thing you
want to do when we're watching child
millionaires the last thing we want them
to do is be nice show the real [ __ ] we
want to see vicious
attacks we want to see families being
destroyed we want to see
because otherwise it's not worth it it's
not fun sorry
i'd rather watch lightfoot
i'd rather watch a live foot shake down
a lambo dealer in chicago than watch
these [ __ ] kids live in a you know in
a big uh applebee's and protect with a
[ __ ] lazy river and [ __ ] dolphins
shooting water and then have to go to
bed every night going oh yeah and
they're also really sweet what we know
they're not we know they're not
what netflix probably has on the cutting
room floor should be the real show that
should be the real show the problem with
these kids is there's like 19 handlers
around them at all times telling them
what they can and cannot say
right many of them love trump
that's what's great many of them are
queueing on like we want that
we want 17 year old like addison ray was
kind of a big trumper
because she's from louisiana and she's
got you know she's
she's she said you know
this [ __ ] likes a little bit of trump
but nobody can be honest because she's
such a brand now but we want it we want
to see addison ray in a maga hat
that's what we want
she doesn't support trump well yeah of
course i mean now you don't you got
money of course of course you go to
netflix gives you a deal i don't support
them now but you did
but that's the thing most of these kids
are like right wing
fanatics why wouldn't they be they've
got 12 trillion dollars
they were raised on like inspirational
quotes and [ __ ] you know like why
wouldn't they be so that's a lot more
fun to see
yo like hillary eats babies bruh
she's [ __ ] babies
but it's a boring show i wish everyone
the best i don't think they're gonna get
a season two